Yeah,
dude of history came back.
If history struck back,
do we would,
I wouldn't make it.
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't make it long.
Ah,
you'd be fine.
People are adaptable.
You're smart,
dude.
Theo Vaughn,
I would lead,
I would think a little bit.
I would adapt.
I'd lay low in the beginning.
You know,
like somebody doesn't pick my battles.
Dude.
You'd have to kill somebody immediately.
You have to find the first
person in your group.
The week is person and kill
them in front of everybody else.
Yeah.
If you were going to do that,
the person wouldn't have to be either a
terrible person who is victimizing other
people or they would,
uh,
have to have attacked
first who'd have to be,
or they would have to been such a piece
of shit that people were rooting for
you.
Like somebody who was real
chatty and you just ask them,
did,
there's no way.
I'm sort of trying to survive like,
uh,
like uh,
you know,
the second coming of of the universe
and some dudes chatty and my group,
bro.
Oh,
that's not,
especially with like,
he fucks up some hunting parties.
You're out there like sneaking
up on a pig and he's like,
oh my God,
it's so hot out.
You fucking the pig runs
away and everybody's hungry.
Chatty would be the first man I
think about that kind of stuff.
Like if a plane crash,
I already know I'm planning ahead.
Did I'd eat a Vietnamese guy.
Why?
Cause it's easier to start or move.
If you attack somebody bigger,
he eat somebody bigger
in front of other people.
It's going to alarm people.
You got to eat a small person.
So stature is important.
I think if you come down a Viet people
aren't going to be that upset at you.
What?
The Vietnamese people
are going to be super.
So what are you talking about?
Somebody whose dad,
they're more understanding of things.
Dude,
this is a character you're playing.
No,
but if you eat a black dude,
you eat a black lady
and her family is there,
they're going to be pissed.
So you think it Vietnamese
person and we'll let you slide.
I think that they'd be much more
forgiving over a couple of day period.
I think,
uh,
like our relatives.
I definitely think there'd
be super pissed at you.
But what is interesting is like
Vietnam was one of the few places where
Americans can go back to Vietnam and they
don't seem to hold any grudge at all.
Exhibit a
exhibit a man.
Honestly.